in my hero academia i can confidently
say that the war arc
has been the best we've seen in the
series so far it serves as the
combination of several storylines that
have been built up over the last couple
of years
and as you're about to find out it has
been well worth the wait
today i'm going to review part one of
this arc where i'll explain a decent
chunk of what's happened so far
but do be sure to hit that sub button so
you can stay up to date with parts two
and three when they come out
i also might need to do a part four in
the future because as of recording this
video the arc still isn't actually over
so we'll see how much more material we
need to cover after part three is done
as you would expect there will obviously
be heavy manga spoilers
as most of this content will likely not
be animated until season six of the show
whenever the hell that's going to be
so if you'd rather stay spoiler free
then i'd strongly advise you stop
watching now
if you want to get straight into the
actual war itself then you can skip to
the timestamp on screen
but right now i'm going to briefly
explain why the war is happening in the
first place
for those of you that might not know to
start with
the public safety commission tasked
hawks with infiltrating the league of
villains
and in order to gain dabby's trust it's
implied that hawkes killed his fellow
hero
best genus this allowed him entry into
the league
where he's built a solid relationship
especially with twice
but also a few others off screen and
this has allowed him to discover their
plans
and relay information back to the heroes
in coded messages
meanwhile after being captured in season
4 kirigiri was sent to tartarus prison
where it was discovered that he is a
highly intelligent nomu made from the
corpse of a guy called shirakumo
this was isaac's childhood best friend
that died during their time at ua
and i did a review of that whole
backstory if you're interested
after izawa and present mic are brought
to tartarus shirakuma manages to briefly
override his nomu programming
and give the heroes a small hint that
assists them in locating the creator of
the nomus
dr garaki on the other side of things
sugaraki and the league defeated a group
known as the meta liberation army
and were able to take over therefore
adding a hundred thousand soldiers to
the league of villain ranks
not to mention a ton of new financial
resources
this new combined organization has been
renamed into the paranormal liberation
front
and they intend to destroy society as we
know it
for the last few months shiggy himself
has been undergoing a grueling procedure
at jakku hospital which is the location
that shirokumu has now helped the heroes
to locate
once shiggy's operation is complete
he'll have an unrivaled power that will
allow the paranormal liberation front
to finally put their plan into motion
now the public safety commission
were aware of the rising power of the
villains after the whole incident in my
line academia where shiguraki
literally nuked the city and so prior to
his operation
the commission demanded that every hero
student at ua
participate in mandatory work studies
which led to the endeavor agency arc
this was an unprecedented move and in
the words of isawa
they were mobilizing the kids for war in
the present day
the pro heroes intend to catch the
liberation front off guard
by simultaneously attacking them at the
hospital and all their bases across
japan
one of which happens to be the sick
mansion to help do this
the pros have dragged along a ton of
students to help but as you can see
most of the kids were told it was just a
work-study trip
and many of them don't fully grasp the
nature of what's about to go down
okay so the actual war kicks off with
endeavour
leading many of japan's top heroes into
jakku hospital
with the intention of finding dr garaki
and shigaraki
as they storm forward heroes like
ectoplasm and that one guy from gentle
criminal's childhood
begin to evacuate patients from the
hospital just in case the place turns
into a battle zone
before too long endeavour comes face to
face with the doctor who
at this stage is believed to be totally
quirkless the doctor screams and begins
to run away but izawa trips him up with
the binding cloth
and then activates his erasure quirk
once he does this
dr graki begins to rapidly deteriorate
and he looks almost like a crawling
skeleton
this is due to him having a secret
mutation quirk called life force
which has allowed him to live well past
his cell by date and yes for those of
you wondering
the professor is capable of disabling
certain mutation quirks
present mike then gives the doctor a
hard slap across the face
as izawa ties up the villain with the
binding cloth these guys are on a
mission
to get revenge for their boy shirakumo
whilst this commotion is going on
the rabbit hero mirko charges on forward
into the hospital by herself
which makes sense because she's never
shied away from her belief that teamwork
is for simps
as she progresses deeper into the
hospital she encounters the morgue which
is where dr garaki conducts all his
horrible experiments
and at least five nomu appear and
attempt to block her path
luckily for mirko she has amazingly
thick thighs and uses them
to legit decapitate every single one of
the nomu in her way
truly she's just she's just amazing
whilst the doctor is being restrained by
izawa
and known with the size of a baby whale
bursts out of the ground
and inside its mouth is another nomu
with drills for hands
this no mood drills straight into dr
garaki killing him
instantly or at least that's what i
would have said if it didn't turn out
that the doctor
was a fake the whole time the real dr
garaki had made a double using twice's
quirk
and let that replica handle his
day-to-day responsibilities at the
hospital
this gave the real dr garaki more time
to focus on his masterpiece which of
course
is tomorrow sugaraki with his double now
destroyed
the real doctor decides that you know
maybe it's time to make a quick escape
before the heroes find out about the
secret lab like i said
this place is located deep into the
hospital so the hero shouldn't be there
for a few minutes
but it contains you know a bunch of
higher nomos not to mention
hundreds of quirks that have been stolen
and replicated over the years
obviously the doctor doesn't want to
leave all this research behind
but the situation does call for it and
so he asks john the nomu
to warp him and shigaraki to a different
location however
before that request can be fulfilled
mikko busts into the lab
killing jon in the process and causing
the doctor to start hearing final boss
music
the number 5 hero immediately turns to
the doctor but she's kind of unsure
whether or not he's the real deal or
just another clone
at this point most of the other heroes
can't come to support her
as they've been completely swamped by
nomus in an incredibly chaotic battle
but that said cross manages to break
away from the fight
to try and reach her mirko lunges
towards the doctor to give him a
superpowered kick
as it will confirm whether he's a
duplicate or not during these few
seconds before she makes contact
the doctor thinks to himself that there
are higher nomus in the lab
that could take out mirko however they'd
still need several hours to fully
stabilize
in this situation he doesn't really have
a choice but to use them
so he pulls out a device from his pocket
to activate them
it looks like mirko is about to stop him
by kicking his arm
but one of these freaky little nomus
appears out of nowhere to distract mirko
this one possesses twice's double quirk
so mirko instantly one shots it with a
kick to the brain
and as far as distractions go it did a
pretty good job because mirko looked
away for those few seconds
this bought the doctor enough time to
press the button and bring
five high-end nomus to life the high
ends immediately send mirko flying
and begin to talk amongst each other
about how eager they are to start
killing some heroes
the doctor explains that this type of
nomu exhibits the personality
of the host body which is why each one
of them are made from the body
of battle crazed villains hand-picked by
dr garaki himself
now that he no longer has the warping
quirk at his disposal
the main strategy now is to distract the
heroes for long enough so that shiguraki
can wake up early
currently he's at about 70 completion
and he's still meant to be in that tub
for an additional month
but with this situation the doctor click
cracks on the keyboard for a bit
to speed up the recovery process if
shigeraki can wake up before any heroes
can capture them
then yeah things will look pretty good
for the villains at the very least
that's what the doctor is hoping
the high-end nomus completely just gang
up on mirko with a variety of awesome
quirks
including squishy head laser eyes and of
course elephantitis
because they've not really had much time
to stabilize she's able to stand strong
and pummel a few of them even
decapitating this nomu right here
this high end is officially referred to
as robot
and man did he not live up to his
awesome design but that said he was able
to rip half of mirko's arm off in the
process
so i guess he wasn't totally useless
wait whose side am i on again
another one of the high ends went off to
fight crust in the hallway
because if you remember i said that he
had set off to try and help mirko
because he's kind of a big deal you know
he's the number six hero he defeated
several regular nomu on the way to the
lab
and when coming face to face with the
high end he busts out this epic super
move
how his shields physically get that big
i just don't know
at this point the story then switches
perspective and we leave the hospital
and head on over
to the paranormal liberation front
mansion where hawks and the villains
currently are
the pro heroes begin to charge at the
mansion in a fluent assault
and if you look closely you can see
kaminari is also on the front lines
with tears in his eyes tokiyami is also
there but he seems to be a lot more
content about the situation
as midnight says to denki the reason
that these two and a few other students
are on the front line
is because their quirks are too useful
to not be involved
most of the other hero core students
that are in this location are located in
the rear guard instead
which means that they're basically kept
towards the back just to make sure no
villains slip past the heroes in escape
as the frontline heroes charge forward
cementos shows us why he's the ultimate
chad
and uses his quirk to rip apart the
entrance of the mansion
how overpowered is this right here like
just amazing stuff from cementos
many of the villains now start to charge
out of the mansion ready to fight
and we see this cocky electric quirk
user ready to single-handedly fry all
the heroes
kaminari is still majorly stressing
about the situation
but midnight tells him that in order to
calm his nerves he should think about
the person
most important to him at this moment he
then thinks about jiro as the scene
flashes over to her
and we can see that she's thinking about
him too in this moment
this gives denki the boos he needs to
clear his head and he absorbs the
millions of volts coming from this
electric user
which means that all the pro heroes are
free to move forward
we also see mudman and the mushroom girl
from class 1b
doing some serious damage to the
liberation army soldiers
not to mention experienced professionals
like midnight and edge shot
neutralizing a ton of villains by
themselves
kamui woods also gets in on the action
as he ties up his fair share of bad guys
whilst this is all going on out in the
front there's an equally as important
series of events happening
inside the mansion with the heroes now
attacking
hawks is now able to finally lift his uh
his undercover facade
and has cornered his best friend twice
in a secluded room
the reason i say this is equally as
important is because if jin is let loose
to help the villains
then the heroes are just royally screwed
hawks himself is very much aware of that
fact
which is why he intends to capture twice
without any resistance
although good luck with that i love this
moment because if you looked at it in
isolation
you'd 100 think hawks is the villain in
this interaction
i mean just look at his eyes those are
villain eyes
jyn breaks down crying as he remembers
how he previously trusted overall
only for him to kill magna and explode
mr cobras arm
and now his new best friend turns out to
be a spy for the heroes
the guy really cannot catch a break
hawks tries to reassure him that after
twice has done his time in jail
he'll help the guy start over with a new
life because deep down twice is a good
person
however naturally when you're being
betrayed by a close friend you don't
really want to hear any of this
and so despite hawks's intimidation with
the feathers
jin unleashes his ultimate move which is
of course his infinite doubles sad man's
parade
and on this occasion he is especially
sad we first saw this move during the
myvlan academia arc
but for those that aren't aware of it
this is when he makes copies of himself
who then make copies of themselves who
make copies of themselves and just so on
and so on and then you basically have an
army of twice's
the only downside is that each new
double becomes physically weaker than
the last one
making them progressively easier to
destroy now you might recall that when
the heroes began to attack the mansion
i said that all the villains were
running towards the entrance to go help
out the other villains
but there was one man who started
walking in the complete opposite
direction
as you can see this was darby who was
the one that brought hawks into the
pound normal liberation front in the
first place
he knew from the very beginning that
hawks was just putting on an act
and he immediately sets off to find
hawks and just obliterate him
whilst twice is using his sad man's
parade the number two hero is able to
quickly destroy each of the duplicates
due to the epic speed of his feathers
and also partly due to the lack of
durability
of each of the clones hawke says that he
would never allow something like
sentiment to trip him up it's at this
moment that he actually starts to
consider killing twice
and i'll explain why in hawks's own
words
he tries to take out villains pretty
quickly because when neither side gives
up
then somebody has to die as it stands
jin keeps making new clones over and
over
and he even creates a little mini mini
league of villain squad as well
we then see hawks take out a recording
device and he then offers his former
friend
the chance to come quietly this
recording is to cover his own butt
just in case he needs to execute twice
because as you'll remember
heroes generally aren't meant to kill
people which possibly adds more feel to
the theory that best genus is still
alive somewhere
but we'll see where that goes by
recording what's about to go down it's
kind of showing that he offered twice a
way to get out
but you know if he didn't comply then he
might just have to kill him hawks then
slices twice across the chest in a
bloody move
and then pins him to the ground with a
feather sword to the face
as twice expresses his disdain for hero
society
and his regret being tricked yet again
hawkes begins to push his sword down
and kill twice but is stopped when dabby
appears out of nowhere
and floods the room with his intense
blue flames you can see hawks has been
completely taken by surprise here but
his hero training kicks in and he rolls
out of the flames
and saves twice from the fire as well
even though he was just about to kill
the guy
dabi then steps on the number two's head
and shatters his visor in the process
he then proceeds to ignite his leg on
hawks's face
which is just just unnecessary it's
unnecessary darby you don't need to do
that
before we get into what happens next
with that there's a giant sanctuary
underneath the mansion which is where
gargantua marcia and a bunch of the
other liberation warriors
are currently hiding the heroes have
strategically blocked most of the exits
for the villains who were in this
sanctuary
but there's one that remains tamaki uses
an
awesome new move to block most of the
villains coming out of the entrance
i mean my guy is galloping like a horse
while swinging around his tentacle arms
which each have pineapples and melons on
the end of it
you have to give him an a plus for
creativity for that one toki army is
then sent out in front
as it's his job to block the last
remaining tunnel so that none of the
villains can escape
this tunnel is a good domain for dark
shadow to be unleashed
because the lighting is pretty minimal
so we can operate at nearly full power
it's at this moment that for the first
time ever we get to see tokiyami's
ragnarok move in
action which is essentially him
harnessing the power of berserk dark
shadow that we previously saw
during the forest training camp in
season three as this attack rummages
down the hallway
redestro shows up and goes straight into
his gigantic muscly stress
form this is what he previously used in
my vlone academia
to go head to head with shiguraki and do
significant damage to deja city in the
process of that battle
but dark shadow manages to overpower him
thanks to destro's prosthetic legs
notwithstanding the pressure the reason
that he has prosthetic legs
is because shiguraki made him uh cut off
his own legs during the maven academia
arc
it was a crazy arc so if you're watching
this and haven't watched that then i
actually did a chapter review of my
video in academia if you're interested
consequently redestro is pushed back
through a wall
and the falling debris manages to clog
up the tunnel trapping
all the bad guys underground if you're
wondering about why gagantemakia isn't
getting involved
he's just sitting in the corner waiting
for shigaraki to wake up
because even though they're being
attacked he only responds to direct
orders
from the big boss which just plays
further into my theory that he is a nomu
if he wasn't a nomu then you'd imagine
he'd at least try and help out a little
bit here
but yeah for now heroes don't really
have to worry about him
with his part of the mission done
tokiyami then hops inside fat gum's fat
and asks the big guy where they got such
detailed information
on the paranormal liberation front to
which fatgom reveals that it was hawks
who was feeding the hero's information
he also theorizes to tokyami that hawks
is probably still in the mansion
somewhere too
and as we know he's not wrong okay so
back to the situation with darby
hawks is getting completely stomped on
and i do mean that in literally every
sense of the word
however the number two is not down for
the count yet as he uses a feather sword
to drag himself and twice
away from the blue flames remember that
he can manipulate each individual
feather with telekinesis
so this is a pretty smart application of
that power
debbie doesn't really care though as he
notes that most of hawks's feathers are
gone
not to mention the fact that this is a
terrible matchup for hawks anyway
because his weakness is flames as i
mentioned earlier
dabby reveals he never believed a single
word from what hawks has said from the
start
and hawks begins to realize he's at a
massive disadvantage at this point
so he has to prioritize the mission
rather than his own life
whilst hawks is thinking about what to
do twice jumps out of the way
and asks dabi to shoot hawks with his
flames which of course he does
sending the number two hero crashing out
the window behind him
twice is a bit injured but he starts to
move forward again and dabi lets him
know that everyone is waiting for him
downstairs
in dabi's words twice alone is enough to
make quick work of
all the heroes the two share a rare high
five
as jin stumbles forward to join the
others but then suddenly out of nowhere
the man who goes too fast appears
directly in front of twice
having been blown out the window by
derby and then instantly circling around
pretty impressive for someone who's had
a bunch of his feathers burned up
dabby is shocked by the number two speed
and proceeds to say something that hawks
was not expecting to hear
for those that don't know hawkes was
enrolled on a special hero program from
a pretty young age
that required him to literally give up
his name which makes things all the more
suspicious
when darby literally just blurts it out
loud in the moment
i did a theory video explaining how i
think he knows this but getting back to
the war
we see that hawks is visibly taken aback
by what he's just heard
this gives darby sufficient time to fire
off a blast which causes hawks to
retreat upwards
and leave twice alone for the time being
as a result twice is able to get out of
this room
and get a quick look at the battle
that's going on down below he thinks to
himself how he needs to protect everyone
because they accepted him when no one
else would you can almost feel his
regret in this moment
as once again he's responsible for
causing his friends even more pain
by falling for hawks's lies and giving
him incriminating information in the
process
to quote twice himself he says that his
whole life just seems like a man falling
lower and lower whilst getting tricked
along the way
in a last-ditch attempt an exhausted gin
creates a double of himself
and sends it off to find toga but as
this is happening we can see a long
feather sword
start to appear behind him naturally
this is hawks
who looks particularly menacing in this
panel and he plunges the feather sword
directly into twice's back
during the overhaul arc we saw how toge
used a handkerchief to keep twice's face
wrapped up
and it's something that he's treasured
ever since he even mentions it two hawks
when the hero tried to kill him for the
first time as the sword digs into twice
we see this hanky flying to the air with
blood surrounding it
the story then flashes over to toga and
compress who have been captured by a
hero who has one of my personal
favorite new quirks from this arc as the
unnamed hero gives his heroic monologue
the double that twice had sent off
earlier appears and just delivers a
brutal fatality
as a result his friends are now set free
and they express their absolute joy at
being able to see him
compress asks twice to make more doubles
but he reveals that he can't actually do
that because it's taking
all of his strength right now just to
maintain this form
if you look closely you can see this
clone is beginning to melt away
and this is almost certainly related to
the fact that the real twice is dying at
the same time
with the little time that this double
has left he reveals that hawks tricked
him
and apologizes to his friends he then
moves towards toga and gives her back a
handkerchief
although this is just a double of the
hanky which leaves a smudge on her face
which is pretty gross but very
sentimental at the same time
in a really emotional moment that i will
be personally disappointed if this
doesn't make me cry in the anime
but uh twice's double truly begins to
melt away into nothingness
and whilst that's happening toga thanks
him for saving her
you really have to feel for toge here
because twice was truly her bestie
so she's seeing a copy of her best
friend die in real time
in his final thoughts he reminisces
about how being there with them
meant that despite all the crap he dealt
with in his life he was still a happy
person
and with that twice is officially dead
his double melts away and the real
version of him is just upstairs
um just yeah lying as a corpse
so um yeah my friends that was the end
of the first part of the war arc
and what an ending it was our boy twice
the deadpool of my
academia is the first major casualty of
this war so far
when i first read this moment in the
manga that's when i changed my profile
picture on youtube
from mirio to twice and i've not changed
it since i really like this character
and it was a shame to see him go out
the way that he did anyway but at the
same time you can definitely
see where hux is coming from because if
twice was let loose he could have
replicated
all the league of villain members the
high end no moves anything you could
have thought of
he would have been an incredibly
dangerous asset during a war like this
so it was almost necessary to take him
out to at least give the heroes a chance
anyway if you liked the video then
please like share and comment your takes
down below
it will let me know if you enjoyed it
and motivate me even more to do part 2
as soon as i can thanks for watching as
always and peace out